look how much we've evolved steven sober
you know what you're talking about
because marvel every day is banging our
minds
[Music]
what's going on there reject nation we
are going to watch today from the cosmic
wonder he's so great at these videos
every marvel project upcoming and
rumored over like the next few years
let's see what's in store what we might
not have heard of and whatever you know
how i do hit that like button if you
haven't enjoyed our video check out more
from the cosmic wonder let's watch it
now the future of marvel studios really
is truly exciting right now with over 20
projects coming either on film or to
disney plus there's no shortage of
exciting projects coming and since
there's been so much revealed over the
past year and so much rumored to be
coming today i'll go over every project
you can expect to see down the line both
confirmed and rumored and the rumored
ones are very very exciting now i won't
spend much time on the projects that we
pretty much already know about by now
for example multiverse of madness is
obviously the next movie that we're
going to be getting and pretty much
everybody knows about that i had heard
about that for love and thunder which is
coming not too long after christian bale
is going to be in the film natalie
portman is returning as jane foster
thor the guardians of the galaxy are
going to be in it for a bit these two
films i am most excited for i don't
really hear too much chatter about thor
love and thunder but i have a feeling
that when that trailer comes out that's
gonna be the one i'm most looking
forward to oh people are gonna go ape
[ __ ] for that what i mean by that is if
they like showed the doctor strange
trailer moon knight thor love with their
all in the same day i'd be like i know
it's thor loving that yes and the
guardians in there with tycho waititi
jane as thor come on man this is going
to be an exciting [ __ ] gonna be funny
and entertaining and action-packed i'm
just picking on the reinvention that
ragnarok was but we also have a lot more
coming like moon knight coming to disney
plus in march then she hulk and miss
marvel then we have the i am groot
disney plus series that should be coming
this year as well what's funny is that
the director it's not funny i don't know
i said what's funny it's just the same
you say right director or the show
writer of she-hulk did verify recently
that she said something along the lines
of that even though a lot of these shows
have been a lot more serious that she
hulk is going to lean way more into
actually being a comedy have more of
those elements where people are going to
come out and be like why does mc try to
make everything funny
and then so people will hear what she's
saying it's like i know those shows have
been more serious then everyone's gonna
attack her and go what are you talking
about the mcu always has comedy in it
no no no but this will prove that women
can be funny
maybe maybe i don't want to get too
ahead of myself big maybe someone's
going to be the first and it could be
tatiana maslany
there's a funny name yes
i'm not touching that
complete i am groot looks funny too and
then there is a werewolf by night now at
first werewolf by night was just kind of
a rumor it was rumored to be a disney
plus halloween special for 2022 but now
we've actually seen werewolf by night in
the moonlight trailer if you missed him
he's the guy that moon knight is beating
the absolute crap out of in the trailer
debatable way to take the werewolf by
night disney plus show is pretty much
confirmed now at this point wait a
minute i would chalk that up strictly to
a rumor man yeah so that could be a
jackal according to your number one
competition paul from heavy spoilers
why'd you say the name for werewolf by
night that would be really cool to bring
to life i would adore that i wouldn't
say pretty much confirmed though i think
it's
a debatable
we then have black panther two wakanda
forever and a lot of us are really
excited for this one but mostly very
curious because we want to see how
they're going to handle it after the
passing of chadwick boseman then to end
2022 we have the guardians of the galaxy
holiday special and james gunn did say
that this is going to be important to
watch the next year oh really
christmas ties heavily into the future
captain marvel 2. the very very highly
anticipated guardians of the galaxy vol
3 where they will introduce adam warlock
and
the villain of the film the high
evolutionary this is also supposed to be
the last film of the guardians franchise
so we're kind of expecting some deaths
in this movie i'm throwing my hat in the
ring for who's gonna die
this is me just purely speculating all
right i have no i haven't even read a
rumor about this movie
i think dave bautista is going to get
the ass oh definitely drax gets axed he
drax out
officially james gunn himself is going
to enter frame
shoot him go i was never really as close
with you as you make people think
john cena all the way
i got a real wrestler i wanted
you were a stepping stone get out of
here go act the echo series now this is
a newly announced series this was
announced during the disney plus day of
2021. now they introduced echo to us in
the hawkeye series she was played by
alaqua cox and did a fantastic job now
spoiler alert if you haven't seen the
hawkeye series yet but they introduced
kingpin in the series and by the end
they revealed that it was pretty much
kingpin who was responsible for the
death of her father now in the comics
kingpin actually kills him which doesn't
happen in the series but he was
responsible for ronan going there and
killing him now at the end she ends up
shooting him in the face and a lot of
people think he's dead but this has
happened in the comics before ekko
shoots him in the face he goes blind in
both eyes but eventually recovers
regains his sight and becomes the
villain again and that is what we're
expecting for the echo series kingpin to
be the main villain and daredevil to
show up considering the fact that she is
his love interest in the comics they are
in a relationship together so the echo
series which should be coming in 2023 is
going to be a pretty exciting series
dude i love the idea of charlie cox all
these chicks he's been banging through
the daredevil series man just left and
right knocking it out of the park
charlie yeah proven stephen soderbergh
wrong in every turn maybe it'll just be
a romantic series maybe there'll be no
action at all i'm blind you're deaf no
way we complete each other completely
our senses of touch are just as high as
they could possibly be let's get it on
we then have ant-man and the wasp
quantum mania which is going to
introduce the villain king the conqueror
we also have what if season 2 coming
that year and then we have the iron
heart series now as far as the plot of
the iron heart series goes we don't
really know too much about it yet in the
comics she's granted access to stark
technology and iron man armor and we
could probably assume that this is going
to be somewhat the same in the comics
fortunately we will learn more about her
story in black panther 2 wakanda forever
where she is going to be making her
debut and this has been confirmed by
marvel studios president kevin feige
then we have a movie that a lot of
people are really looking forward to
captain america 4 with sam wilson as
captain america the falcon and the
winter soldier had a lot of success and
not too long after the show's finale
aired malcolm spellman who was the
writer of that series said that he will
be returning to write a script for
captain america 4. so this movie has
been confirmed by somebody over at
marvel although they haven't officially
announced it yet i am very excited for
that movie i don't even know what to
expect i'm not familiar at all with sam
wilson from like in the comics itself i
haven't read congress sam wilson as
captain america guiltiest charts however
after falcon and winter soldier kind of
how that was not one of the most talked
about shows and then the captain america
franchise the movies are some of
marvel's most successful it's gonna be
an interesting experiment it would seem
like will people tune in as much will it
make as much money will it be as well
received do they need to you know
ensemble him up and will they bring any
of that subtext they were trying to talk
about in the show to the movie i'm sure
they will the captain america films are
big geopolitical thrillers but whoa whoa
whoa keep your politics out of my
marriage armor wars starring war machine
little is known about this disney plus
project besides the fact that it is
going to be based off of war machine don
sheedle is returning to play rhodey and
i'm sure we can expect some tony stark
and possibly captain america tie-ins
here what
tony stark tech that falls into the
wrong hands and that's where the title
comes from armor wars like the
spider-man movies really exciting
projects coming up like blade marvel has
already announced this and mahershala
ali is going to be playing the vampire
and also according to rumor we have a
world war hulk movie coming this isn't
confirmed yet much is known but we
assume that it is going to follow the
world war hulk storyline where the
illuminati
earth's heroes trick hulk into going
into outer space and to another planet
he ends up getting a wife and she gets
pregnant but she dies due to an
explosion of the ship that hulk was sent
there in and hulk is filled with rage
and comes back to earth and defeats
pretty much all of the heroes on earth
then he puts them in a stadium and makes
them all fight each other this is
definitely the type of hulk that fans
have been wanting to see since we saw
professor hulk in avengers end game we
also have another wakanda series
i don't think they're going to do it
that sounds like a massive detour
that's so awesome that sounds amazing
i'm so dark in the multiverse you never
know that sounds insane it does
my favorite part of that though was when
warren said he gets a wife
yeah they just deliver him one
[Laughter]
right away she's just like yeah i love
you we're doing this we're together and
then immediately she's dead and he's
angry again but they could do some like
sci-fi bleak dark ass [ __ ] if they did
that oh yeah the thing is it sounds like
to really make it its full potential
you'd have to make it a couple movies at
least yeah you get ridley scott
we also have another wakanda series
coming when ryan coogler signed on to
direct a disney plus wakanda project he
actually signed on for a multi-year deal
so expect another wakanda project coming
at some point in time now we can't
forget about loki season 2 because that
is coming although we do not have an
official release date for it but they
left us on a major cliffhanger last time
and last year on disney plus day they
announced a agatha harkness disney plush
show agatha house of harkness as the
official title so we could be getting
directed by mike flynn origin story here
or she gets out of west view and wanda
spells somehow perhaps something happens
in multiverse of madness and perhaps
we'll see her in the film then of course
we have a fantastic four we do not know
when they are coming although kevin
feige the president of marvel studios
has said that it is in development right
now so much right actually get the movie
within the next two to three years then
we have nova a project that i know a lot
of people are going to be really excited
about kevin feige himself teased the
development of a nova project at marvel
studios in early 2021 reports then came
out that the fantastic four was iron a
2023 production start and that nova
would also follow a similar schedule so
perhaps we'll get a nova project whether
that's a movie or a disney plus show in
2024. do you know anything about nova
not really unfortunately i don't really
know much about nova either is nova
involved with the nova core
nova idea
we've contributed to the video
then of course we will probably get a
what if season three depending on how
well season two goes we'll also be
getting marvel zombies which has
officially been in oh yeah yeah sure
disney plush ship this isn't 100
confirmed and not a lot of people know
about this but in 2021
a trade report focusing on hollywood's
top 100 attorneys for 2021 referenced in
a koi series being developed at marvel
studios this could be one of ryan
coogler's projects that he signed on for
and not much is really known but we
presume it might go into ocoee's origin
then of course we have deadpool we're
not sure if it's going to be a deadpool
3 or simply re-titled
but ryan reynolds breaks the fourth wall
as deadpool slash wade wilson so
everything will definitely be addressed
and made fun of not much is known about
this at all but a lot of fans are really
hoping for a deadpool kills the fox
universe and that's how he gets into the
mcu
do it that would cause so much
controversy absolutely it would why not
i would love it let's eat it up toss it
toss that grenade right in there i mean
the fox universe has almost no
continuity to hold on to anyways i mean
you would you would keep it in tune with
the idea that we have a multiverse but
why do we have to kill the fox universe
i don't know i mean it seems like you
would want to salvage some of those
parts for sure like there's no need he
could just hop to a different universe
yeah it seems like a lot of effort for
just you know eventually the same
conclusion he just goes to it
differently
why can't you just let them be in peace
in their dying corner of the world then
of course we have spider-man 4 our
fourth spider-man movie with tom holland
now based off of the post credit for
spider-man no way home we assume that
the villain is going to be venom but
that's not all the spider-man we have
coming we have the animated series
spider-man freshman year coming we don't
have an official release date yet but
what we know is that it'll explore peter
parker's time as he becomes peter parker
in the series in a style that celebrates
the early comic book
2019 san diego comic-con kevin feige at
the very end said fantastic four and
mutants which he then later clarified
means x-men they have the rights now
back to the x-men and kevin feige has
confirmed they are indeed working on a
project now pretty much nothing is known
about this at all but fans are really
excited to finally see the x-men in the
mcu interacting with other heroes
there's also been rumors about an
illuminati project coming to the mcu
believed to be formed during multiverse
of madness and then go on to get their
own project in the comics the illuminati
wow that'd be a wild
superhero group mr fantastic of the
fantastic four professor xavier of the
x-men tony stark iron man of the
avengers black bolt of the inhumans
doctor strange of himself and namor the
submariner of atlantis now obviously
some of these characters have not been
introduced yet and some have died so
it'll be curious to see what the actual
team is then of course we have such an
expensive show
this has been confirmed by marvel
studios we just don't know
does look like they are setting up a
young avengers team we're unsure if this
will be a disney plus show or an actual
marvel film but as we get more of the
avengers like america chavez and miss
marvel we'll have a better idea of
what's going to happen you know what's
crazy like back then it feels like
a fortnight ago
when people
were so just amped up about the avengers
that crossover like when are the
avengers gonna come or they cross paths
when's the next avengers movie oh this
nexus but now it's like we i don't ever
hear people even talk about
the next adventures we just call like
it's a
the adventures are here but we don't to
talk about the next avengers movie well
there's so much crossover already
do the crazier [ __ ] now it seems like
avengers movies become whichever one in
the tandem has the most crossovers at
the time look how much we've evolved
steven sober you know what you're
talking about because marvel every day
is banging our
and to top it all off there's rumored to
be a ghostwriter project coming we're
not sure if this will be disney plus or
a film which i'm hoping is actually a
film and fingers crossed that i hope
it's disney plus that's what we want
right now so as you can see we have a
lot to look forward to with marvel in
the upcoming i would say five to six
years not to mention there are projects
out there that we have no clue about
that they're probably going to blindside
us with that are going to be awesome but
out of everything i listed here what are
you most excited for in the upcoming
years let me know captain marvel 2.
don't forget to like the video and turn
on those two stay up to date on all the
latest news that'll be the surprise song
too
he did not talk about shanghai too
racist he left asian people off the
table mm-hmm he talked about wakanda
like 18 times no [ __ ] that's not how you
make up for your racism freaking joe
rogan over here oh joe warren
anyway guys if you haven't subscribed to
jre go check them out on spotify and
that's where you'll find more of this
kind of marvel content listen we gotta
do a patreon of the day shout out and
thank you to warren for helping us out
with this video roll that annoying ass
all right guys we got a shout out today
jean
jeter jean
our handsome artist photographer
photographs many beautiful people on his
instagram page as you can see with this
click little flash of photos right here
oh my so many attractive women we're
gonna do right now is we're gonna choose
the top five hottest ones and the rest
we can just dispose of this joke just go
to the gg nurse page
and follow this guy we follow him you
should follow him too
[Music]